hello everyone here on freecodecamp
looking to build a successful mvp and
avoid making major mistakes when
developing an app or online product
my name is annie okuber and i'm a
software engineer and course creator on
youtube who has also taken part in
fintech incubators such as barclays
techstars for early stage financial apps
i am here to show you why building an
mvp or minimal viable product is a
proven way forward when building out
apps
today so why is an mvp important and how
can the lack of one lead to demise of
your dream startup
here is an example of a failure of an
app with 41 million dollars in funding
back in 2012. the failure of the colors
app could be put down to a few things
but its premature huge launch without
testing the product with an mvp is
considered to be the main culprit the
media attention from the 41 us dollar
million funding guarded quite a lot of
people waiting to download the app
but once they did most of them quickly
ended up using it and deleting it never
to return again
co-founders of colors admitted that they
put out a product that they thought was
good to a massive crowd who ultimately
ended up disagreeing
having an mvp that could be slowly
tested and adapted before such a big
launch could have saved this company
but what exactly is it mvp we will find
out soon enough
by the end of this course you will know
the steps necessary to develop your
minimal viable product and have an
understanding of the mistakes startup
make in order to avoid them yourself and
have a fully working mvp that you can
adapt for your own use cases thanks to
this one hour tutorial
if you ever need to skip to one of the
sections make sure to use the timestamps
in the description below otherwise let's
get going
this course is made possible thanks to a
charitable grant made from retool the
powerful app building platform low-code
solution for creating react-like apps
companies like brex played ram amazon
nbc use retool for their internal tools
and many startups use it to build a
variety of mvps
now
why is an mvp useful to me
mvp stands for minimal viable product
it's when startup to release the most
minimal core product to get things going
in terms of testing and developing here
are four reasons why mvps are essential
to building modern apps
number one an mvp allows you to collect
data and feedback from your customer
base
number two it also allows you to iterate
on what you have before release
building products is an iteration game
the product is forever changing meaning
that you want to choose an approach
where changes can be made quickly and
without too many stakeholders involved
this is where having a small team and
very flexible and relatively inexpensive
tooling at the beginning can be very
beneficial
and another great reason to have an mvp
is to reduce overall development time
and finally a big one for tech startups
is pc funding you might have a great
startup idea in your head but how do you
know it's a great idea you can't show
people the idea in your head let alone
test it out to get feedback and guess
what without that feedback and general
data collection you aren't likely to get
any investors knocking on your door
so you look into hiring a dev team but
uh oh that's expensive and you have no
money as no one will invest you're stuck
in a chicken and egg situation
building an mvp will allow you to spin
up apps or software as fast so you can
get to testing and potentially gaining
revenue to show investors straight away
so we have covered what mvp is and why
you might want to make one but are you
ready to start your entrepreneurial
journey quite yet
to show you how fast this can be done on
your own without having any help and
spending a bomb we will be building out
an mvp that callers should have built in
the first place
okay to build it we will be using retool
note that retool is a platform intended
for building powerful applications but
we are here using it to build a very
simple app to get you started you can
learn more about retool on their website
in the documentation or watch one of my
previous videos where we built out a
couple of more complex applications okay
so what are we waiting for by the end
you will have this app that will allow
you to view all your posts along with
who posted them and who viewed them and
if we click into one you'll be able to
view the whole thing as well as delete
it and upload posts too okay so we're
gonna be using a lot of apis for this
and we're also gonna have this messaging
system that allow you to message users
in your database okay so ta-da there we
go we are messaging in the app as well
right so
let's do it
okay so let's do it let's start off on
the retool platform so it is uh free to
sign up just go ahead and select strive
for free i'm gonna sign in though
because i already have an account with
free code camp so that's what i'm gonna
do as i've used this many many times
before
so here we go this is what the dashboard
should look like as you'll see here
there's some previous uh
projects that i have made let's start
from scratch though i'm just gonna
create new and i'm gonna create an app
so let's go ahead and call this
something i'm gonna call this colors app
okay because we are making a mvp of what
i think the colors app should have
launched with to get going
so
there we
go
okay so here was what the app should
look like to you and me it's got some
boilerplate table with some boilerplate
code as well as all the tabs kind of um
popped up so that we can see them
however we can minimize them if we wish
so just like that and perhaps we should
because the first thing that i'm going
to do is just set everything out in the
ui before we start connecting our
database to mongodb before we start
connecting to aws and all that
so
let's go ahead and do it so as you can
see a table has been populated for us
with some uh just some dummy data we're
not gonna be needing this so i'm just
gonna go ahead and click delete on this
great
now the first thing that we're going to
do is put in a tabbed container so i'm
just going to drag in a tabbed container
and this is going to essentially kind of
symbolize our app itself so here we go
here is our app and in here well we can
actually do a bunch of personalization
so for example first off i can decide
that i want the um
well we can have transitions to slide in
from one to the other
just like so from view one to view two
to view three
and then of course we can rename these
views so i'm actually gonna do that i'm
gonna choose to call this my feed so
like the apps feed i'm gonna choose to
call this my timeline to see a timeline
of all the pictures that i have posted
me personally i'm also going to have a
tab to upload an image from the app of
course we need to do that as an app we
want to be able to upload our own photos
i'm also going to have an inbox
okay an inbox so that we can see
messages and also message other people
from the app itself and i'm also going
to have another one called view this is
going to be a secret one where we can
actually view an individual post
itself
okay so this one is going to be hidden
so i'm going to write hidden true and
that will just mean that we can't see it
here although it does exist and we can
navigate through it by clicking
different things
so there we go that is step one of my
tabbed container we can of course do
many many other things for example if i
want this to be at the bottom well all i
have to do is select the element and
then just scroll down to all the other
options that we have available for
example i can choose to uh change the
color of the footer
so i can choose to have this this kind
of dark
gray
color just like so and of course this
means that we need to
show the footer so just show the footer
like this
i am actually going to drag these tabs
down into the footer itself so that they
are in the middle and i'm just going to
make the alignment center just
like
so okay and maybe let's make this a
little bit bigger so we can see
okay
so
great one other thing we can do that is
kind of cool is actually add little
images to this as well
so for example on my feed i can actually
choose to have an icon which i am
definitely going to do i'm going to
search for the icon so i'm going to have
a little home icon perhaps let's go
ahead and choose this one i think it's
quite cool and position it to the left
let's go ahead and also do one for the
timeline so let's search for something
to do with time and this is a timeline
so let's choose this one
for upload i'm of course going to choose
something to do with uh maybe camera
just so people know that this is for
uploading photos and for inbox this one
is easy let's just choose an inbox so
there
we go
so there we have it this is looking
wonderful there's a lot more things we
can do for example we can choose the
hover text maybe let's just make it like
a lighter color and the selected text
again i'm just going to make this a
lighter gray just because i think it's
much cooler and much neater
whee so there we go we are now sliding
through each of these
let's
carry on
one thing we can do as well to make our
lives easier is actually rename these if
we wish if you find it easier to do so
then please feel free to rename these
i'm quite happy with this being tabs one
but that option is there for you too
now in the header i'd quite like to
actually display whatever tab we are on
so this is going to be our first piece
of i guess retool syntax that you're
going to experience
first off i'm just going to grab some
text and just put it in here like so
making sure that it is in the middle so
let's just get rid of any of this and
make sure it's aligned in the center
so
i'm going to choose to make this an h3
tag so we can use html elements in here
and then i'm going to use these two
double
curly braces so this is some retool
syntax in order to get tabs one so this
tabs one that we were just on and tabs
one comes with a variety of things so if
you click the dot they will pop up we
want to get the selected
label
okay so this just means if i click on
one of these
this text will change dynamically based
off what we have written here
so once again just pick out the element
or pick out the component in this case
it was tabs one you can hover over it if
you need just to get the name and then a
variety of options should show up if you
press a dot and we have just gone for
the selected label
so this is looking wonderful
let's carry on
now i'm just going to put in some more
text here i am actually going to hard
code this just to be my name just
because you know for now i think that's
fine so i'm just going to do that here
so ania kubo is the user of this and we
can of course align this to the right if
we wish and center it this way too
and on the left once again i am going to
put in an image there's two ways you can
do this you can just use a circular
image so if i just show you a circular
image looks like this and we can you
know resize it to
whatever size we want
or if we are very particular about the
size we can actually write our own html
so i'm going to do that for this option
just to show you the difference
so here it's just exactly the same as
you would do in normal html i'm going to
write an image tag
and for my image well the alternative
text for this is going to be
avatar
of user
and then the source of this is just
going to be i'm just going to use an
image of me from the internet again i'm
just hard coding this because we don't
have any data to work with quite just
yet
so here we have an image from me i'm
going to copy the image address
from the free code camp website so there
we have an image of me and now i can
actually pick this out so maybe let's
give this the class of
avatar just like so
and then
this means i can now grab the class of
avatar
and give this a height of 20 pixels
maybe let's make it 25 pixels
a width of 25 pixels a border
radius
of 50
and then maybe let's give it some margin
left
5 pixels
and margin
top
two pixels
okay so there we go i've just made a
custom html element i'm just gonna drag
it in
like so making sure to select the blue
writing
and great and perhaps let's actually
rename this i'm going to rename this to
avatar
image
for us to pick out if we need
now the next thing i want to do is
actually populate our feed with some
posts
so to do this we're actually going to
start working with resources and we have
many to our disposal if we look here in
the resources you will see all the ways
that we can connect so if i go ahead and
create a new resource
we can use all of these databases we can
use all of these apis and we can use a
rest api in order to connect to whatever
api we really wish that uses rest
so there we have it we are going to use
mongodb for no other reason that i had
to choose the database so i'm going to
go ahead and do that
so if you haven't used mongodb already
please do go ahead and sign up once
again we are gonna be using the free
version of it so go ahead and start for
free i'm just gonna sign on with google
because i've already used mongodb a few
times before
so here is my dashboard once you do fill
out all the things necessary in order to
get to here this is what you should see
so under my organization you will see
the projects that i have made so far
so just make sure you're at forward
slash projects
so i'm just going to go ahead and create
a new project my project name is going
to be
retool and i'm just going to click next
okay i am going to be the project owner
so let's go ahead and create a project
just like so
and wait for that to do its thing
so now that we have our project called
retool let's go ahead and build a
database i'm going to choose the free
shed option so please go ahead and
choose that one too
and i'm just going to go with the
suggested
region for me and just click create
cluster
okay so our cluster is being made that
is doing its thing we're gonna have to
fill out some more things first so i'm
just gonna select a username and i'm
going to auto generate a secure password
and copy it and save it somewhere safe
because we are going to be needing that
later don't forget to also press create
user now i'm just going to go down here
and we are also going to add our current
ip address so just go ahead and add your
current ip address this just means that
you will be able to access the database
from your current ip address and we're
also going to add some retool ones in
later as well so that our platform has
access to the database too so once you
have done that let's just go ahead and
click finish and close
okay and go to databases
so now this is doing its thing and what
it has finished we will be able to
connect our database and then also
create our first collection
and great
so the first thing that we're going to
do is actually add something to our
collections we're going to have two
collections we're going to have a post
collection and a message collection so
let's go ahead and add our own data i'm
just going to call this
tests
and the collection name is going to be
posts okay
so please just go ahead and do that now
before we do anything else i'm just
going to connect this to our retool so
let's go back to the overview
and then connect
and then we're going to connect our
application and just take this url right
here and i go back to the connector
resource page that we just started
now what should we call this well let's
just call this colors
and then use the database string and
just paste that in like so and the
password that i ask you to save
just go ahead and replace that here so
we've got the username and the password
we're also going to have to allow these
ip addresses as well as our own so back
in here
under network access please go and add
those three ip addresses of retools so
just go ahead and put in one
put in the second one
so just like so and then finally the
third one as well
okay so just add in those three ip
addresses like so
and that's it and wait for them to be
active
okay
so back in here we have the connection
string we've replaced the password with
our password this is looking good and
once those have been
accepted and they are active we will
test our connection
okay
so just wait for that to be done
and great
so now if we test our connection we
should see connection successful so that
is looking good let's go ahead and
create our resource and then go back to
the resources page
so we've created our resource now let's
go ahead and go back in here
so back to the retool project
browser collections and i'm going to
show you how to create a first post i'm
just going to go ahead and insert
document i'm going to choose to write it
in json as i feel more comfortable with
this and how do we want our post to look
so our post as an object well it's going
to have an image url
okay and it's also going to have a
description
so description of the post itself so we
can have
my
favorite
thai spot for example
we're gonna have the author so in this
case it's going to be anya kubo
which is of course me we'll have the
views
of this post i'm just going to
say that the views are 20
we're also going to have an author
avatar which is just going to be an
image of me and then we're also going to
have a title
so a title of this is going to be
thai dreaming
favor
rit spelt the english way
and then we're also going to have a time
stamp which is going to be iso 8601
timestamp so that we can essentially
order these posts by uh you know most
recent on the so on
and then of course we're also going to
have an id that's going to be our unique
id for now i'm just going to give this
one which is separate to the object id
so now let's fill this out i'm just
going to be using images off the
internet for now again we are going to
be using aws s3 buckets to store our
images but you know we want to see some
stuff now so i'm just going to do this
please be aware though that if these
images go off the internet then you will
not be able to see them anymore because
we have no control over them
so i'm just going to paste an image that
i found on the internet of thailand
and i'm also going to just paste an
image
of myself of the free code camp website
okay so this is it i'm just going to
insert that like so so at the moment we
just have one post i'm just going to
duplicate this
and just create another so this one's
going to be from
john woo he's got
121 views
this is going to be
london
pub
love
idea of this is going to be two
and then the timestamp well let's
actually give this description
my usual spot in
london
and then let's get an image of a london
pub
just put it in like so and then
put in an avatar and get today's date in
iso 8601 format
okay so that's today let's make this
actually
yesterday and insert and i'm just going
to add the timestamp to here as well so
let's edit this
and put in today's
timestamp
okay so we've got two posts here at the
moment
just like so i'm gonna now retrieve
these from the app so to do this i'm
going to just get a resource
so let's just get this down here i'm
going to make a new resource query
this resource query is going to be to
colors
posts
and save and run
and great you will even see a schema pop
up so now if i type in the collection
post or select it from a drop down and
just click run
you will see my two posts okay you're
seeing literally these two posts right
here
wonderful
so this is looking
great
so now that we have to date that data
let's get to using it in order to
populate our feed with a list so let's
get going
so to do this i'm going to find a list
view and just drag it in here like so
it's going to get rid of this for now
get rid of the bottom one too
and let's create
our
list
so the number of rows well we're going
to get our curly braces again and use
the get post data
length in order to
essentially make as many rows as we need
in this case it's going to be two as our
post consists of two posts made up of
the data that we have okay so an array
of those two things
now i'm just going to put in a container
so our first item is going to be a
container and you will see how the list
will just automatically create two of
those because we have two items in our
list it's created two containers
so all i'm going to do is just make this
look a little bit different i'm going to
show a footer i'm not going to show a
header and i'm going to also put in an
icon
so let's search for an icon and just
drag it in here like so
and then this is going to be an i
because this is going to symbolize how
many views we have
so there we go and i'm just going to
align it to the right
let's also put in some text so that we
can actually see how many views that we
are getting on this
visually thanks to our data so i'm just
going to put in some text
and we can now access the data by going
into get posts data and then looping
with an i okay so we're just going to
loop and then retrieve back the views
for those of you familiar with
javascript this should be familiar this
eye to syntax should be familiar that is
how you loop over everything from the
get posts data array in order to get the
values from the object we are looking
looping over so once again i'm just
going to align that to the right
next i'm also going to put in the author
okay so again i'm just going to drag in
some text just like so
and i'm going to go into the get post
data i'm going to loop over each item
and get the author in order to display
who exactly posted this image
and for the image itself well i actually
want to put in some custom html so once
again i'm just going to go into the html
just like so and drag it and drop it in
here
and in here well what do i want i want a
div that is going to be a media
container so let's just go ahead and
write our div and give it the class
of media container just like so
and that's going to hold
so once again i'm just going to put in a
div and the class to this is going to be
image container so let's give this the
class of
image
container
and this is actually going to hold our
image which is a self-closing tag
and the source of this well we're going
to actually use our
two curly braces in order to go into the
get
post data we're going to loop over each
item and get the image
url
okay
so that's what i'm going to do
and then i'm also going to make a new
div that's going to be our text
container
so here is a div i'm going to give this
the class of
text
container like so
i'm just going to put in a p tag
this is going to hold the title so once
again we're going to get
post data
when i loop
and just get the title
okay
so
there we go we're having some issues
with the thai dreaming image i wonder
why that is but we'll look into that in
a bit
so now in the css let's actually pick
out everything that we have to style
which is going to be the media container
for one
and the media container well i just want
to hard code everything so they all have
a height of 200
pixels
and then also we're going to have the
image container
like so and the image container is also
going to have a height of 200 pixels
and then also a width of 100
i'm gonna have overflow as
hidden
so just like that perhaps we can make it
smaller if we wish i'm quite happy with
this if you want to make it smaller and
please feel free to do so
great
and i'm also going to say that the any
image that lives inside the media
container
is going to have a width of 100 to make
sure that any image is you know
stretched out to the width and then
position
relative
and just center it so that means from
the bottom i just want it to be 50
and one last thing
let's get the text container
and let's give it some padding so i'm
going to go with 5 pixels from the top
15 pixels
from the side
and then 8 pixels
and then also 15 pixels
okay and then also i'm going to give it
a background color
and that background color is gonna be
a little bit transparent so i'm gonna go
with
zero zero zero zero point five
the text well the text i'm actually
going to give it
white
so
there we go so we can read it
let's also give this position
relative
and let's give it some
bottom
and let's also move it a little bit
like
so okay so that's what it should look
like just ignore that one for now so
it's kind of like an overlay with the
title like
so
and also maybe let's start any p tags
that live inside the media container so
any p tags that live inside here so we
don't want to affect any other p tags
and have the font size of
20 pixels
great
so that is looking wonderful we've just
created our custom html element which is
going to be this image this is looking
great
so perhaps let's fix this image problem
let's go back in here and see what is
happening obviously just doesn't really
like this url let's see why
i'm not sure but let's find another
image of thailand
i'm just gonna go with this one right
here copy image
and let's just replace it like so an
update
and great so that is looking so much
better
make sure this says overflow
make sure this says
image container
okay perhaps we don't need that this is
looking great
okay so there we have our two posts of
course we can add more we'll do that in
a bit what i want is to actually add a
trigger if we click on this it will take
us to the display of the image itself
just by itself so let's go ahead and do
that
what i want to do is add an interaction
and that's going to be on click and it's
going to control a component that
component is going to be the tabbed
container and i'm going to set the view
to be
view which is if you remember one of the
tabs that is hidden
so that's what i want to happen and when
that happens i actually want to write
another query to get an individual post
so at the moment if i click this it will
just go to the view page i now want to
write another query so let's go ahead
and do that i'm going to write another
query
this query is just going to be get
individual posts so get post and i'm
going to go into the colors
resource
and what i'm going to do is look in the
collection called
posts
so posts and i'm going to use find one
this time because i want to find one
post based on an id so the query i'm
going to have to write is id and then
i'm going to choose the post i clicked
on to get posts again data and whatever
i looped
id
okay so that's all i am essentially
going to do i'm going to preview that
just to see what comes back and once
again let's go to the feed
it's going to save and run this and if i
click on this
that should get
me whatever post i clicked on
id
okay
so that is what should be happening
right now
if i click on this
so all i'm going to do is create an
image
drag it in here like so
and the source of this well it's not
going to be this cute kitten even though
that would be quite nice i'm going to
get
posts
data
this time just the individual post data
not post
data
image
url
okay
so let's try this again
okay so this just means if we click on
here as long with going to the view we
also need to control a query and that is
the get post query so that is looking
good let's go ahead and trigger the
click now
so
i'm just going to get rid of this
click on here
trigger the click
and great so we are getting that
individual post right now we're
essentially running the get post query
another thing we can do of course is add
more stuff to this so let's create i'm
going to maybe put in the author name
again at the bottom so just drag in my
name right here
and then get rid of this and get post
data individual
author okay so i'm just putting my name
right here and then we can also put in a
button to delete it and this will run
the delete query for the post so there's
something that we can also do so let's
go ahead and do that why not
so
to do this well we're going to have to
write a another query so let's go ahead
and get these two tabs up i'm going to a
new query so resource query and this
time this is going to be
to
delete
post
okay
so that is what our query is going to do
and the
collection for this is going to be posts
the action type is going to be delete
one and we're essentially going to look
for the id
of this post
so this post is get post
data id
okay and if we preview this
okay the result says that this should
work if i save this now
we need to now connect the button to
that query so let's go ahead and maybe
say this is delete i'm also going to
make it red just because i think that
red is much more
associated with deleting things so on
click of this now
event handler on click control query
delete post okay so that's what i want
to do
we can also do it that on success
so on success of this post
so here we go
on success we can also be taken back to
the home page so control the component
we want the tabbed container and the
view we want to set is the
feed
so that is also something that we can do
so should we go ahead and delete this
post of course it will mean that we
won't have much data to work with but
you know let's let's just go ahead and
do it in fact i'm just going to
perhaps uh copy this so that we can just
reinsert it back in as soon as we do it
so copy that
and let's check it out
so back to the feed i'm going to click
on this so let's trigger the click
okay we're viewing the image on the view
page
and let's go ahead and now click delete
so that will trigger the delete post
and it takes us back to the home page
however this is still here so perhaps we
need to get all the posts again because
if we refresh this
okay so that is correct so once again
that's fine we can open this up
and on the delete post query so on
success we want to go back to this we
want to go back to the
feed but we also want to rerun the query
that will get all the posts right so we
want the freshest posts so that is what
we're going to do so let's try that one
more time i'm just going to reinsert the
document that we just deleted
so insert that
to refresh this
i'm going to hide that
so now we should see two posts
let's once again just trigger the click
for this so trigger click so we view the
whole image now and then i want to
delete the whole image so then it should
be deleted it should take us back here
and we get the freshest posts wonderful
so this is looking good once again i'm
just going to reinsert that in so that
we have more data to work with
great
so this is all looking good so we've
done the feed
next we want to show the timeline of
just our posts so what i'm going to do
is actually make a new query so resource
query and let's call this get
your
posts
okay
and once again we're going to look in
the colors resource we're going to look
in the collection called posts and this
time we're going to find but we're also
going to write a query for this because
the author of this well we just want it
to be us right so us is here in text two
so we can use the component text two to
get its value
so text to value is gonna be the
username okay so that's just what i'm
going to do right here like so so again
we can also preview that it's annie
akuba so if i preview this here it
should just return back one post which
is the one post i made the author
anyakubo so this is looking good i'm
just going to save it
and all i'm now going to do in fact we
can just copy this right i can copy this
list so i'm just going to hide this and
just put it in here because it's the
exact same thing perhaps you just need
to drag it in here it's the same type of
view that we want okay so that will have
all the same functionality to it and if
we click on it we'll be able to see the
timeline too
okay so that's what we want we just need
to now replace the data that's being fed
into this with instead of going to get
posts we're gonna get go into get your
posts data instead okay so that's the
length of this and now here
we're also going to
make sure that we're using the correct
queries so get your
posts
get your
posts
okay and i believe that should be it are
here to get
your posts
otherwise we're using a different query
for this get
your posts
and that should be it
okay so once again here we have our feed
it should have everyone in it
unless we've deleted something
okay so here's our feed of the two items
if we go on the timeline we just see all
my posts as any kubo and if we click on
this posts or trigger the click it
should be taken to the view of the post
however it would seem that if we're on
our timeline the trigger will also need
to be changed
get post
trigger
this is going to have to be another
query
so let's write another query so you get
your post
so we've got our individual post we're
also going to write a resource called
get your post individual get your
post
okay and once again it's going to look
in colors it's going to find one this
time
and we're going to look in it
so i'm just going to save this because
we're going to essentially just copy
this what we did for the individual post
forget your post individual but instead
of getting the posts
we're gonna get your posts plural id
that we clicked and save and run which
means that if we're now on the timeline
the trigger that we want to hit is get
your post
and not get post
okay so hopefully that makes sense let's
check it out i trigger this
it should go to here and now we can
use get your post individual to render
this and also get your post individual
to render this
and on the delete
make sure that is saved to the
collection posts
and on the delete
once again we're going to have to write
a new query
so
make sure this is delete
your post
like so and once again we're going to
look in the collection posts we're going
to delete one
and what do we want to delete well we
want to get the id of
your post that you are viewing
and
on success
we want to
control
the component we want to control the
component
tabbed container set the current view to
feed
and then also on success we want to
rerun the query to get all the posts
great
so this is all looking wonderful so once
again let's go on our timeline
let's trigger the click
and we are indeed getting the correct
post
so this is all looking wonderful
so now that we've done that let's carry
on so we've got the feed we've got the
timeline
we'll work on the upload next i just
want to work on the messages so for this
we're actually going to make a new
collection so let's go ahead and go back
in here and just create a new collection
that this time is going to be called
messages just like so and click create
now what are our messages going to look
like well our messages are each going to
have again a time stamp as we're going
to want to filter out you know the order
on which the are coming in so timestamp
is going to be necessary we're also
going to have a from
so for example this is gonna be from
anya kubo
and it's gonna have a two and the two is
gonna be to john woo
john woo
and of course we're gonna have the
message itself i'm not very imaginative
so apparently i just text john woo
hey there
because you know i lack any sort of
imagination
so that is my message and of course we
need a time
stamp so i'm just gonna stick that one
in of today and now and just click
insert okay so that's what our message
is are going to look like i'm just going
to duplicate this one and make this one
perhaps maybe
five minutes in the future this time
from john
woo
to
anya kubo going
hey
because again this is a really bad chat
so there we go okay we have two messages
in uh i guess chronological order
now let's get to getting these messages
and showing them based on the user that
we click so this is gonna be quite cool
let's do it
so this is going to involve some more
list views so i'm going to get a list
view and on the left i'm just going to
show my users that are available to me
at the moment it's just going to be me
and john wu and then we will have
another list this time of the
messages themselves
so another list
view
just
over here to display the messages
okay
great
and finally i'm gonna have a form
because the form is going to submit the
message that we type
so i'm just gonna work that in here
just like so i'm gonna get rid of the
header i'm going to keep the body
and then i'm just going to have a text
area as well so let's put in a text area
like
this
and perhaps let's change the label to
type
your message here
and then
the value
is going to be enter your
message
okay and then this can be submit sure
why not
so there we go so first things first
we're going to have to write a query to
get unique users okay because at the
moment we're going to use the posts the
filter out all the unique users so for
this we are going to have to um in fact
let's not write a query let's write a
javascript transformer to do this
so i'm going to say this is unique or
get unique users
and what we're going to do is
so the data that we're going to be
working with is the
get posts data i want to get all the
posts every single one
and of course at the moment we only have
two posts by two users but when we add
another post from myself i'll show you
that this is working
so let's define unique users
or unique authors
to be more precise and i'm going to use
object of values to get the value
of the data
i'm going to reduce
the array of posts
with the post itself
and if
there is no array
of
posts
post author
make sure that is spelled exactly the
same way
then array of posts
post
author
it's going to be the post
and then we're going to return the
array of
posts
okay
so that is how you'll get all the unique
authors
oops
so essentially what you're doing is
looking in the array and you're
filtering out all the object based by
the author and just returning the unique
authors okay so that's what i am doing
here
so let's save that
so now this just means that on here
so first off i'm gonna get the
so get unique
uses value and get its length
next i'm just going to drag in some text
like so
and instead of this
i'm going to let's just make this a p
tag
and i'm going to go into get
unique users value
first one
and get the author name
oops make sure to add the object
okay
make sure to add that that's important
and make sure that this was in the right
space too
okay so great so we are mapping out
the names on to
text
elements we can also get the user's
avatars
so i'm just going to use the circular
image for this
just drag it in like so
just make it small
and drag that back in here so once again
we're going to go into the get
unique users value and loop over each
one to get the avatar
image so author avatar
and
great
so we have our users here
the next thing that i want to happen is
i want to trigger a click
so if we click on
so perhaps p we should put this in a
container
just so that it's very obvious if we
click on
a user
so there we go i'm just going to get rid
of the styling of this so i'm gonna get
rid of the header and then just make
this a little bit bigger
and i'm just going to also get rid of
the border because i don't really want a
border on these i just want them to be
kind of transparent
okay great so now let's trigger a click
so what do we want to happen well if i
click on here i want to see all the
messages between any and anya so that
will be null that will just be me so if
i click on john will i want to see all
the messages between me the user and
john woo so let's go ahead and do that
i'm going to essentially
write a event handler for this
but first off we're going to have to
write some you guessed it more queries
so the query i'm going to write this
time is get
messages to user
i'm going to look in the colors
resource the collection we're going to
look in this time is messages and we're
going to find
anything
that has from
and then
the messenger user so from
john essentially so i'm just going to
hard code john wu in here for now
and then to
me so the user which is text to value so
i'm just going to use that instead of
hard coding it okay
so
great
so that is the query i want to run let's
see what that returns back that should
just return one message back that is
correct so that is our get messages to
user query let's write another query
making sure to save that one and this
time it's going to be
get messages
from user user being me
okay
and this time we're going to
get the resource query colors look in
the collection messages
and this time from
is going to be
me
so that is text to value
and 2 is going to be john which i'm hard
coding at the moment but this won't be
hard coded for long
so that is a way to get messages from
and to each other and i want to get both
of them and then sort them by a
chronological order
so once again i'm going to use a
javascript transformer to do this and
this is going to be get all
messages
okay
so for this i'm going to define all
messages
and all messages is essentially just
going to be
get messages from user
data
and i'm just going to concat it with
get
messages
to use the data okay so that's all i've
done and now we're going to filter them
by timestamp so cons descending
messages
and i'm going to get all messages i'm
going to use the javascript method of
sort
to essentially sort them
by the time stamp so
a time stamp so the first items
timestamp we're sorting one after the
other
we're going to use locale
compare
b time
stamp
okay and then we're just going to return
back the descending messages so let's
preview that
or message is not defined
making sure to spell everything
correctly of course
return to sending messages
okay so there we go the messages are in
descending order as soon as we add more
we will see that
okay so let's save that and that will
run that transformer will run this is
looking good
okay so on
trigger of this so if we click this
container we're going to have to add an
event handler and
that is to essentially get messages from
user that's correct but also get
messages
to user
okay so that's what i'm doing i'm
essentially rerunning those queries and
by rerunning them it will trigger this
transformer to do its thing as well
one other thing i want to do is actually
set some temporary state so i'm going to
show you how to do that we can set
temporary state because i want to save
the user that i have clicked on
so i'm going to save this as
send
messenger
user
and the initial value for this is just
going to be
null however i want to set this value so
i'm going to set
on click i'm going to set temporary
state the state is gonna be messenger
user and the value of this
i wanna set to get
unique
user value
i
author okay so whatever i clicked on
here i want to save it to state of
messenger user
okay and i'm doing this for a reason i'm
going to show you right now
so
first off actually let's map out the
messages onto here right so let's
actually do this in containers i'm gonna
drop in a container
and then i'm not gonna have a header
so let's get rid of the header
and then in here i'm just going to drag
in lots of text really so this will say
the name of who this is from
i'm also going to have
the actual
message itself of course
so actually let's also have
the date before we do anything else
we've got a name and a date perhaps
let's move the date up here
and then i'm just going to make this a
little bit thinner
we're going to drag in some more
text here
and we are now
going to actually get our messages
so we're going to get all messages value
i'm going to loop
to get the
time
stamp
okay so that's what we're doing however
also going to wrap this in a new date
object because we want to change this to
a more readable format
so we do this with two locale
string and call it
making sure that this is all in curly
braces too
okay wonderful and this does not need to
be
curly braces any
more
okay so that's just
uh a more readable format
i think
uh local
date string let's do let's not do the
time
great and then also the name we need so
once again i'm gonna now go into
get all messages value i'm gonna loop
over everything that comes back and get
the from
okay
and of course we need the message itself
so i'm just going to drag that below i'm
going to get all messages value i and
actually get the message itself
okay and then perhaps let's also put in
a divider
and great
so cool so now if we perhaps just click
this trigger
we should just see messages from
anya and john wu
and of course if we click on this
we should just see messages from anya
but to do this of course we just hard
coded
john woon here right we need to get rid
of this so all i'm going to do is now
get the state that we saved so that's
the messenger
user
value
okay and just save and run that
and do the same for here so instead of
hard coding john woo
messenger
user
value and save and run it
so now
if we trigger click
i don't know why there's so many of
these others because we need to
get all messages value
length
great
okay so again if we now click on john
woo we'll see all the messages from anya
and john woo
and if we click on anya we should see
nothing
great
now let's get to actually adding
messages okay so that's what i'm going
to do next let's get to it
so let's go ahead and add a new resource
query this is going to be add message
singular
i'm going to use colors the collection
is going to be messages
i'm going to insert one
so insert one message
so what we're going to do is just create
the object so the timestamp i'm going to
use the new
date
object in order to get that
from i'm going to
just use text to
value because that's what we've been
using which has been using this
to is going to be again we're going to
get the
uh state so the messenger
user values whatever we save to state
because that's going to be who we are
messaging it's whoever we clicked on
here right so whoever we're in
conversation with and the message well
the message
is actually going to be whatever the
value of the text area is
so text
area 1 value so that's all it's going to
be i'm just going to preview that and
save it
maybe just format this a little bit
nicer
so that is it
save
and then we're going to have to add an
event handler for this so on submit
control the query add message that
sounds good to me
and then on success of this right so
once this is run on success where we
want to essentially get messages from
user again
right so
do that and get messages to users again
so we want to rerun those so that it
gets all the messages again okay so
let's test it out i'm going to click on
john wu trigger click so we're on john
woo
test and click submit so that should run
and then we re-get all our messages and
that shows up
wonderful apart from the text is not
really showing up i don't know why
text ariel 1
value
let's have a look in here
let's get our messages
test we seem to have got one needs
to delete this
so the message here
uh we've used two s's that's why okay so
that's my bad just use one s
click save so let's do that again submit
you should rerun the messages
and ta-da there we have it so i'm just
gonna delete this one with the two s's
and this is looking good so everything
is now working
let's carry on so we've done the feed
we've done the timeline we've done the
inbox where we can message specific
people
okay and see all their messages and then
go
hello and literally message them
on the app
this is looking
wonderful okay we can make this also a
fixed height so that then we have to
scroll if we wish that is totally up to
us perhaps that is a good thing
especially when we're going to be
getting you know more details later so
let's make this fix too so those two
things are going to be fixed i'm just
going to move this up so no matter how
many more users we have no matter how
many messages
this should stay the same and then we
could just scroll
perhaps we should do that for the feed 2
in fact let's make this fixed
and let's make the timeline
fixed as well so everything is now
fixed
great
so one last thing to do i want to be
able to upload things from the app
itself
let's do it
so for this i'm actually going to have
an image preview because i want to see
what uh image we have uploaded
so we're going to have an image preview
like so and then i'm just going to have
an image but of course the image won't
really show up unless we have something
to show in here so what i'm going to do
for this is say that
we're going to get the s3 uploader so
actually let's actually find the s3
uploader component s3 uploader and just
put it here
under the image
and this just means that i can get the
s3
uploader
last uploaded file url and display it
once we have uploaded something and of
course i also want a
text input to be able to show the title
in here too okay so that's all i am
going to do
and then we can also position the label
to be at the top and this is going to be
the title of the post
and we're also going to have a place to
put the description of the post as well
of course the author is going to be
asked because this is our app so we
don't need to worry about that so
description and the date is just going
to be whatever date that we have okay so
there we go
this is looking
wonderful
and next we just need a button that will
confirm the post so we can post it to
our database as well okay so we're going
to be posting it to our mongodb database
so let's just say this post and then
let's change the color of this i'm just
going to change it to be this lovely
orange right here
great
so this is looking good let's carry on
so we're going to do the add post query
because that is an easy one i'm going to
add a resource query let's call this add
post and this is going to go into the
colors resource it's going to look in
the collection
posts and it's going to insert one
and once again we're just going to have
a time stamp which is going to be
new date
we're gonna have the image url which is
going to be
the s3 uploader one
last
uploaded file url
i'm gonna have the title which we're
literally just going to get the
text input one from text
input one value same for description
we're going to go into the text value 2
so text input to value
we're going to get the author which we
know by now is text
to
value
author
avatar making sure that it's felt
exactly the same as in our database and
let's just get the avatar image for this
so avatar
image
source
views we're going to hard code as zero
and the id well i'm just going to
generate a unique id using the uuid
method
v1 and call it
okay so that's our object to create
a new post
let's save it
and on success we just want to get the
query get all the posts again okay we're
going to rerun the post so save that
wonderful
and once again on success
we also want to control the component
and go back to the home page so let's
get the
tabbed
container
view and go to
feed
great so those are the two things that
will happen on success
so the next thing we want to do is of
course
hook up the s3 loader so let's go ahead
and do that
so let's make a new resource query
this time let's create a new resource
and i am going to
select amazon s3
let's go ahead and call this
amazon
s3
and then the bucket name well this is
stuff that we're going to have to do in
amazon right now so let's do it
so let's go to amazon
i'm just going to select i am user and
click next so of course i have already
done all this sign up please go ahead
and sign up it is free just make sure to
sign up with the correct
steps i am doing right now and click
sign in once you have done
so here is my s3
dashboard this is what you should look
like if in doubt just make sure to
go to the same urls that i have
okay and i'm going to have to create a
bucket so i'm going to go ahead and
create a bucket here my bucket name is
going to be
retool
bucket
just like so
and i am just going to
uncheck this
i acknowledge this
and create a bucket
okay
so there we go there is my
bucket let's go ahead and click that
now under permissions i'm going to have
to put in a bucket policy
so i'm just going to edit this
and paste in this i've written before
making sure to change this to
retool
bucket
one or whatever you call your bucket
okay
so just go ahead and do that
and
save the changes
one other thing you're going to have to
do is change the object ownership so
please scroll down
and edit the object ownership
and simply check this box right here for
acl enabled and acknowledge it as well
okay and save
you're also going to have to enable
cause so just go all the way down here
click edit and paste in this code just
like i am okay so take your time take a
break pause this and make sure that it's
exactly the same and then click save
changes
great
so this is looking good let's carry on
so the s3 bucket name well we know that
this is
retool
bucket one
then we're going to go into here
under users and add a new user
i'm going to call this retool
anya
i'm going to need an access key
i'm gonna add it to admin
next
review
create user
okay so here is our secret access key
make sure to make a copy of that
somewhere and save it
and then we're going to go back in here
and paste it in here
and then we also have the
access key id
okay
and let's just test the connection
great and let's create the resource
so now when we go to the upload
page
and select the s3
uploader the resource we're going to
choose is ania s3 the bucket name is
retool
bucket
one
and this we're gonna have to change to
public
read
and that should be it okay so now let's
try upload to s3
so i'm going to upload this image of
loften
and ta-da there we have the picture
now i just want to hook this up properly
so that when we post this it gets posted
to our database so we're going to have
to add an event handler and that is to
add posts at a singular post and the
method is trigger
okay so now when we click the post
button this should work let's fill out
the fields of the title and the
description making the app in full mode
and just go ahead and click post and
we'll be redirected to the feed and you
should see our image here even though
we're not seeing the image why is this
let's have a look at the code one more
time
ah we need a space between the end
bracket here
so just make sure that is there and
please apply this to any other images
that we have in the app
okay and there we have it i hope you've
enjoyed this tutorial it was really fun
uh showing you how to make an mvp that
people can use you know you can actually
test it out on people get feedback you
know this is a work in progress and this
only took us a few hours so i think it's
the perfect solution for building mvp
products and you know really getting
your ideas out there thanks so much
again for watching and i will see you
again soon